five on the idea of Education the school
year is winding down and it's a perfect
time to thank the teachers for all their
hard work that's a teacher appreciation
week not just a day at least a week
Lauren negretti uh spent some time at
Marion Earl Elementary she's live now
this morning with how parents and kids
can show their support we have so many
great Educators out there they they need
a little pat on the back definitely we
guys some of the same themes are there
Heather hate to call you out but apples
are out I did catch up with some of
those kids and staff at Marion Earl the
principal Veronica hunt recommends
coffee chain like Starbucks or Amazon
gift cards that teachers will likely
wind up spending on their students you
know some families bring in Donuts as
well and there's also the route that
their students are taking writing
handwritten thank you notes hunt says
the school is planning special events
all week for their Educators one of
several CCSD schools given a much
deserved thanks
not just the week of teacher
appreciation but every day our teachers
work so hard for all of our students to
make all of our schools not just here at
Marion Earl a wonderful place for our
students to be yeah
awesome you know it's especially
important to shine a light after all the
difficulties that the pandemic caused
principal hunt says since returning to
the classroom and having in-person
events they have seen an increase in
test scores and attendance and coming up
in the next half hour some fifth graders
at Marion share their favorite thing
about their teachers back to you guys
wow yeah there's so many great things to
do I'm still admiring the mural well on
the wall there in the school that was a
beautiful school good stuff thanks
Lauren appreciate it